in this video i will explain the
similarities and differences between
correlation regression and causality and
as always let's get right into it
as you already know from our video on
correlation correlation analysis
examines the relationship of variables
but beware later in this video we will
discuss in detail why a correlation does
not necessarily mean there is a causal
relationship one question might be
is there a correlation between the age
at which a child speaks his or her first
sentences and the later school success
if the correlation analysis shows that
the two characteristics are correlated
we could now investigate whether there
is a causal relationship if there is a
causal relationship school success could
be predicted by the age at which a child
speaks his or her first sentences using
a regression so the question now is do
we have a causal relationship in our
example in this case the answer is very
easy because we have a temporal
separation
if there is a correlation between the
age at which a child speaks his or her
first sentences and the later school
success
it is clear that the time at which a
child speaks his or her first sentences
influences later school success and not
the other way around
later school success cannot influence
the age at which a child speaks his or
her first sentences but beware it's not
always that easy let's look at the next
example
let's say at the end of the school time
you make an intelligence test with
pupils and ask them about their high
school grade
after you've conducted your survey and
you are analyzing your data it will
surely turn out that there is a
correlation between intelligence and the
high school grade but now comes the big
question mark is there a causal
relationship
of course we could now simply set up a
regression model
and define intelligence as an
independent variable and high school
grade as our dependent variable then we
could predict the high school grades by
using intelligence but this is not a
proof of causality i think now we can
look at what causality means and under
which conditions one can speak of
causality
causality means that there is a clear
cause effect relationship between two
variables a common mistake in the
interpretation of statistics is that
when a correlation exists it is
immediately assumed to be a causal
relationship here i have a suitable
example for you
the american statistician daryl huff
found a negative correlation between the
number of head lice
and the body temperature of the
inhabitants of a group of islands
a negative correlation means that people
with many lies generally have a lower
body temperature than people with few
lies
and now the interpretation of the
inhabitants
the inhabitants of the islands concluded
since lies reduce fever they are good
for health
so their assumption was that head lies
have an influence on the body
temperature in fact the right conclusion
is the other way around
an experiment could prove that high
fever drives away the lies
so the high body temperature is the
cause not the effect
therefore one cannot speak of a causal
relationship just because there is a
correlation
for causality there are exact
preconditions
but what are the conditions for
causality
when can we speak of a causal
relationship
there are two conditions for causality
first there is a significant
relationship that is a significant
correlation this precondition is of
course quite easy to test we simply take
the correlation coefficient and check if
it is significantly different from zero
the second condition can be satisfied in
two ways
first it is satisfied if there is a
temporal ordering of the variables
so variable a was collected temporally
before variable b
furthermore the second condition can be
fulfilled if there is a theoretically
founded and plausible theory
in which direction the causal
relationship goes
if neither of the two is true
which means that there is neither a
temporal order nor can the causality be
justified by a well-founded theory then
we can only speak of a relationship but
never of causality thus it cannot be
stated that variable a influences
variable b or vice versa
let's take a look at our examples again
in the first example where the question
is whether the age at which a child
speaks the first sentences
influences later school success
there is clearly a temporal component
the measurement of when the first
sentences were spoken is clearly before
the measurement of later school success
the relationship cannot be the other way
around
if one has a great school success by a
lot of studying and support this has of
course no influence on when the first
sentences were spoken
on the other hand if we measure
intelligence and the high school grades
at the same time
we do not have this temporal component
in order to be able to make a statement
here we have to look for a well-founded
theory of which variable influences
which one
if no such theory exists
no statement about causality can be made
there's certainly a high correlation
between intelligence and high school
grade but it could also be that people
who study a lot have good grades
and have acquired their knowledge to do
well in an intelligence test
so in this case the intelligence and the
grades were determined at the same time
of course you can avoid this by taking
the intelligence test before school
starts then you can be sure that the
school had no influence on the
intelligence test for sure this requires
a lot of time and effort because you get
the results
many years later and the same people
have to be interviewed at two different
times
now you have a good overview of what
causality means and we can go into more
detail about regression
check out my video on simple and
multiple linear regression for that i
look forward to seeing you
you